hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar bringing novel
biomarkers from research to clinical use
I am Christina mahalik of lab roots and
I'll be moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
laberd's the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
our webinar today teachers faculty from
the Department of Laboratory Medicine
and pathology at Mayo Clinic in
Rochester Minnesota and the webinar is
sponsored by finger tech bingo tech is a
biotechnology company based out of
Hennings fir'd germany the company
develops innovative biomarkers for a
prediction diagnosis and therapy
muttering of acute kidney injury
congestive heart failure and septic
shock to learn more visit Shingo techcom
Mayo Clinic is a nonprofit organization
committed to clinical practice education
and research providing expert
comprehensive care to everyone who needs
healing
the Mayo Clinic Department of Laboratory
Medicine and pathology and its reference
laboratory Mayo medical laboratories
provide advanced laboratory testing and
pathology services to support more than
4,000 healthcare organizations around
the world revenue from this testing
supports medical education and research
at Mayo Clinic complemented by
collaborations with diagnostic and
biotechnology companies the department
maintains a robust diagnostic test
development program launching more than
100 new tests each year to learn more
visit Mayo medical laboratories comm so
let's get started you can post questions
to the speakers during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them in the drop down box
located on the far left
of your screen labeled ask a question
and click on the send button questions
will be answered after the presentation
to enlarge the slide window click on the
arrows at the top right hand corner of
the presentation window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support tab found at the top right
of the presentation window or report
your problem by typing it into the
answer a question box located on the far
left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and this offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I will
now present today's speakers Allen Jaffe
MD Jeffrey musin PhD and Lesley Donato
PhD all from the Mayo Clinic in
Rochester Minnesota dr. Jaffe is a
consultant and a chair of the division
of clinical core laboratory services he
holds a joint appointment in the
Department of Cass cardiovascular
diseases dr. Jaffe is a professor of
laboratory medicine and pathology and
also a professor of medicine dr. mucin
is co-director of the cardiovascular
laboratory medicine after graduate
school he spent three years as a
postdoctoral research fellow supporting
Mayo medical laboratories esoteric test
development dr. mucin research interests
include lipid and lipoprotein testing
dr. Donato is co-director of
cardiovascular laboratory medicine and
co-director of the hospital clinical
laboratory and point-of-care testing she
is a consultant in the division of
laboratory core laboratory services in
the Department of Laboratory Medicine
and pathology our presentation will now
begin with dr. Jaffe the floor is all
yours welcome to this seminar in the
development of novel cardiovascular
biomarkers
I'm the chair of the division of core
clinical laboratory services here at the
Mayo Clinic the cardiovascular lab is
part of my division and since I'm still
a practicing cardiologist I have a
special affection for that lab in the
interest of full disclosure I'm a
consultant for swinger tech which is
sponsoring the seminar
the Mayo Clinic is a storied medical
institution started over 150 years ago
by Charlie and we'll mail the clinic
mantra today is the same as it always
has been the needs of the patient come
first as you may know the Mayo Clinic
and Rochester has been rated as the top
Hospital in the nation by u.s. News &
World Report's there's an integrated
practice of 4500 plus physicians 3,800
plus residents and fellows and over
58,000 employees
our total budget for research and
education is over 1 billion dollars much
of it provided by institutional funds
the Department of Laboratory Medicine
and pathology is one of the largest
laboratory operations in the world is
dedicated to development of novel tests
that will help our mission of caring for
patients both here at Mayo and around
the globe through Mayo medical
laboratories what we would like to share
with you today are some of the efforts
we have made to develop new testing we
start first with dr. Jeffrey mucin who
is one of the directors of the C V lab
and who will discuss the development of
some novel testing by mass spectroscopy
for serum eyes with his finger lipids
that appear to aid the detection of
residual risk in patients with heart
disease then his colleague and
co-director dr. Leslie Donato will
discuss our developmental activities
involving novel protein assays being
developed in conjunction with sphingo
tech with that we will start with Jeff
thank you dr. Jaffe and thank you all
for having me a part of this today so I
was going to start with a test that has
already gone through the process here at
Mayo Clinic from just being an idea to
being now clinically ordered and in use
in our cardiology practice so this test
started as many do when researchers
approached us with an idea and what
happened in this instance was a group of
metabolomics experts came to us with
some data that they had gathered using
an untargeted lipid approach using mass
spectrometry and what they did was
analyzed hundreds of different spinkle
lipids and they used a well
characterized cohort of patients that
both had instance of CB mortality and
then carefully age gender and other
matched controls and they identified out
of that list that there were three
ceramide species that all seemed to be
elevated very significantly amongst the
cases since these three species were
somewhat similar we thought a more
dedicated method
it could be developed that would look
into that had potential to be of
clinical use so the three ceramide
species identified in that untargeted
study were ceramide 16 ceramide 18 and
ceramide 24 won all three of which were
increased in cases with cardiovascular
disease and each was independently
linked to poor outcomes additionally a
fourth ceramide species 24 0 at the
bottom of the screen although not linked
to any disease did seem to add value as
a normalizing factor since it was the
most abundant ceramide found in all
patients so at this point we did a
little more background research and
wanted to look into just what ceramides
are and there's been quite a bit of
basic science over the years found that
ceramides are actually a complex lipid
synthesized in all cells and they're
very biologically active their signal
molecules and they tend to accumulate
particularly in tissues not suited to
lipid storage in situations of caloric
excess hyperlipidemia inflammation or
ischemia all cells as we said contain
the machinery to make ceramides either
de novo or rapidly by converting from
sphingomyelin additionally it's been
shown in basic science research that
atherosclerosis are enriched with
ceramides that ceramides are carried
through the circulation associated with
April lipoprotein B lipoproteins
that they increase the amount of LDL
infiltration into the vascular wall and
that they promote aggregation of LDL
lipoproteins once within the vascular
insulin additionally ceramides are
associated with inflammatory cytokines
that are known to be involved in
cardiovascular disease as well as
disruption of the nitric oxide signaling
pathways and vascular dysfunction so
based on the preliminary data it seemed
like this would be a very promising
biomarker additionally the same group
that
and it brought us forward the entire
--get of data was able to show that in a
specific case study using a specific
measure of just these three metabolites
of these three specific ceramides that
they were highly predictive and that the
adjusted hazard ratio for each of them
continued to be independently predictive
of cardiovascular death even after
adjusting for other biomarkers such as
LDL cholesterol april-b
statin age smoking etc so at this point
we decided to begin the development of a
multiple reaction monitoring LC mass
spec assay and the first challenge we
encountered as we as we went into this
project is illustrated in the cartoon
you see the problem is of the four
analytes we want to measure there is
several orders of magnitude difference
in their concentrations in most
individuals plasma the reason this
becomes somewhat of a struggle is
because you need to balance the amount
of response we get across those
concentrations and make sure that we
have enough signal that it's out of the
noise and yet not so much signal that
we're saturating our detector and as you
can see the four different ceramides
span quite a range so we spent lots of
time finding the perfect LC conditions
and internal standard ratios etc to make
sure that we had a decent signal to
noise and linearity across all four
species and across the relevant range is
required at each and what you can see
here is in the final method we were able
to demonstrate linearity for all four
species across the relevant ranges as
well as an loq or a limit of
quantitation with a imprecision of less
than 10% for all four
going on we would do as we would with
any other assay that we want to make
clinically available we assess the
precision or imprecision and found that
we could with the conditions we had
created measure ceramides all four
ceramides in plasma samples with the
precision of less than 10% we then went
on to identify the stability so that we
could know how long samples could be
treated in various conditions as well as
the ideal storage and transport
conditions to get specimens to the
laboratory and you can see that here
turns out we can allow ceramides to be
stored eight hours ambient 24 hours
refrigerate or 30 days frozen we went on
to then assess a normal value study
which we did by recruiting and
vigorously vetting inclusion criteria to
make sure we had a normal healthy
population of whom we measured in whom
we measured the ceramides of the
different varieties we found that it was
not a normal distribution amongst our
healthy population but rather a log
normal distribution and again it fits
that different orders of magnitude as
we've been struggling with through in
the end we had a plasma ceramide test
available by mass spec using plasma EDTA
plasma and then with these stability
conditions so while we were going
through the analytic validation to
ensure that we could offer a clinically
robust method other groups were
continuing to assess the clinical
utility of this test in various well
characterized cohorts one of those was
the a thorough remo study in which
patients undergoing angiography had very
sophisticated imaging of intravascular
ultrasound as well as near-infrared
spectroscopy of their coronary arteries
and when patients results were compared
with their ceramide measures it was
found that again
ceramides were increased amongst
patients that had more lesions and worse
lesions those that had more necrotic
plaque or higher lipid core burden
and following these patients for one
year found that the ceramides were again
associated with outcomes
another study published in the European
Heart Journal and a different group of
patients found again that the ceramides
were highly linked to outcomes despite
being adjusted for typical covariates
considered in cardiovascular disease and
that the normalization of ceramides to
that fourth ceramide was caused an
increase in the predictive utility as
part of our own validation not only did
we do an analytical characterization of
the testing but we evaluated the utility
of ceramides using the method we had
developed in the patient cohort that we
had recruited at Mayo Clinic's and what
we did was recruit about 500 patients
that had undergone an elective coronary
angiography for a variety of reasons and
we excluded those patients that would be
at the highest risk such as those with
diabetes or an organ transplant with
known renal failure or a prior coronary
artery intervention we found the same
values as what had been previously shown
in the other studies ceramides were
highly predictive of having a subsequent
event and that if you normalize the
ceramides to the ceramide 24:08
increased the predictive utility
at this point we were wanting to make
clinical tests available but since we
had three values plus three normalized
values we thought it would might be a
little bit confusing to put this into
clinical practice and working again with
the group that we'd initially approached
us about this we developed a score and
that score is fairly simple in that you
give zero one or two points based on the
percentile that the value is in of those
six different measures so you can have a
full scale of zero to twelve points and
then if we go back to the cohorts that
we measured we found that the score
actually was not influenced by
triglycerides or any other cholesterol
measure which was good that shows
something of independent information and
that incidence of events increased as
the score increased with this we then
decided to give the red yellow green
reporting scale that clinicians often
use when interacting with their patients
and discussing test results and we
labeled scores in various categories as
either low moderate increased or
high-risk looking at the angiography
patient seen at Mayo Clinic and tested
for their serum as massara might
concentrations you can see that
event-free survival is significantly
altered depending on what the
individuals baseline Sarah my risk score
was
and that this holds true regardless of
their baseline LDL concentration those
individuals on the Left had an LDL
cholesterol less than 100 MiG's per
deciliter and still the score was able
to identify those at highest risk of
developing cardiovascular events the
score is also very synergistic with CRP
which is a commonly used inflammatory
biomarker of cardiovascular risk and you
can see here that the incidence of
events regardless of if your CRP was
higher low it still increases with the
increased score
SCOR has also been applied in two other
cohorts and tested in European
populations each cohort had over 1,500
patients and again as the ceramide risk
score increases so did incidents of
cardiovascular death
finally in a primary prevention study
the score was shown to again be
predictive of cardiovascular outcomes
and this shows that the utility is broad
beyond just secondary prevention and
also includes the healthy primary
prevention populations
additionally some studies very small
studies at this point have looked at the
ability to modify ceramide
concentrations in a small group of 24
healthy normal subjects given
simvastatin for two weeks they found a
significant decrease and ceramides the
same was seen amongst men with metabolic
syndrome taking receive a statin for
five weeks
another study has looked at the effect
of aerobic exercise training and found
that there's a significant decrease in
plasma ceramide concentrations following
a few weeks of a 12 week program of one
hour a day of aerobic exercise and then
finally and this is most recent and this
was a study performed by a group not
affiliated with Mayo Clinic or any of
our previous collaborators and they
looked at a subset of the Preta med
trial which was an interventional trial
where patients were put on either the
Mediterranean diets or a controlled diet
and what they found was those
individuals given the Mediterranean diet
fared better and those individuals that
had ceramide increased ceramide risk
score given that the Mediterranean diet
actually had outcomes similar to those
individuals that would have had a low
risk score to begin with so this
suggests that a dietary intervention is
highly effective and that the ceramides
are able to identify those individuals
who are able to benefit from the
intervention so in conclusion we were
able to take the concept of a test
looking at that was first thought up
from untargeted lipid omics and bring it
to a clinical clinically or durable and
currently used test at the Mayo Clinic
practice and with that I will turn
things over to dr. Donato to talk about
some more tests that are in the pipeline
thank you dr. mucin for that
presentation so Jeff has now given you a
very nice example of an in-depth example
of a taking a test from the basic
science into the clinical clinical or
durable realm and that test required
quite a lot of development in our
laboratory for at for assay development
since it was a mass spectrometry assay
measuring multiple analytes that we
needed to optimize parameters in our own
laboratory to be able to offer it and
then do the analytic and clinical
validations of those assays now we're
going to switch gears a little bit and
talk about some other novel biomarkers
that are in our pipeline that aren't as
well down the pipeline as Jeff just
talked about and these two I'll be
talking specifically about two
biomarkers and this is in collaboration
as has been mentioned before with our
collaborators at sphingo Tech the two
biomarkers that we'll be talking about
today are pro and capelin and pro neuro
tenzin so let's get started with these
so we'll first talk about and Kaplan's
in Catalans are endogenous opioids
they're mainly released by heart and
kidney tissue and the receptors for and
Kevin's are highly expressed in the
kidney as you can see in the diagram
here
it turns out however that in Kaplan's
themselves are very unstable peptides
and in this graph you can see that
that's the blue peptides shown it in the
diagram here and so as a surrogate
because because these and calf ones are
very unstable it's very hard to measure
them in the laboratory as a surrogate
marker our collaborators at some Ingo
tech have developed an assay to a
different peptide called Pro and
ethylene so Pro and Catalan is or P en k
is the is the parent protein but if
measuring an internal peptide here
called P NK from 119 to 159 in the amino
acids you can see that we're targeting a
specific peptide within Pro and kefflin
that's much more stable and can be
assayed and our it is produced in equal
molar concentration to end Kevin's but
doesn't suffer from the problem of
instability so they have developed of an
immunoassay based platform that will
specifically target this peptide this
internal peptide to the pro and kecil
and protein the parent protein that is
easily measured in the laboratory
why would we want to measure pro and
Catalan well it turns out that Pro a
Catalan is inversely the concentration
is inversely correlated with glomerular
filtration rate or GFR so renal function
as you can see here with increasing pnk
quartiles
you can see decreasing in EGFR on the
y-axis
and several studies have been done
looking at Pro and Catalan
concentrations in different models of
varying renal function in this
particular study was intriguing to us in
the practice in the laboratory as well
as our physicians in practice because it
looked at patients undergoing coronary
artery bypass or cabbage
surgery and looking at those individuals
who went on to develop acute kidney
injury and as you can see from this
diagram here from this data serum
creatinine values increase after about
significantly increased after about in
the hours post-surgery about two days
whereas pro and capelin concentrations
increase much earlier in the course of
those patients those twenty individuals
within this cohort that went on to
develop acute kidney injury post
operation and so that is attractive
obviously for identifying these patients
earlier on in their clinical course to
then hopefully intercede to try to
prevent that acute kidney injury from
occurring or mitigates the the
downstream effects
so this data along with many other
published studies using pro and Catalan
in renal different renal models prompted
us in the laboratory to look at this
biomarker more closely so the question
is you may be asking yourself okay you
have a new a new novel biomarker what's
what's next what what does the
laboratory do next and in their
evaluation if they're really interested
in evaluating it well what you have to
do for any any biomarker like this is
look closely at the literature what
assays essay or assays if there are
multiple that are being used because as
a laboratory indecipherable assays would
you like to develop or
dedicate your time to evaluating in this
case of course we partnered with bingo
tech the company who developed the assay
for pro and Catalan and then obviously
you have to decide whether your
laboratory has the means the resources
to devote to evaluating these this novel
biomarker so you first have to figure
out the clinical need and interest in
your practice population of course
you're your physician population and
then internally in your laboratory look
at your resources so equipment this
could be equipment this can be personnel
this could be financial this could be
certainly study samples as well patient
samples that you'll need to use when
you're doing both the analytical and
clinical validations so all of these are
things that the laboratory should think
about when trying to evaluate whether a
biomarker should be evaluated in-house
if also if all signs point to yes then
the laboratory and the laboratory
director can then move on to the next
phases of evaluation and those of course
are both the analytic and the clinical
evaluation of that biomarker so for the
analytical evaluation here's the chance
to evaluate all all the assay
performance specs of the assay under
under examination so in the design and
dr. Newton outlined this very nicely in
his presentation the design will always
include similar parameters for any
biomarker under evaluation these are
always precision of the assay at
different concentration ranges
throughout the analytical measuring
range you want to evaluate the accuracy
of the assay the measuring define the
measuring range of that assay define the
reference intervals in a healthy
population or a reference population
whatever it is you use for that
evaluate analytical specificity so what
could potentially interfere with the
numbers values that you get in the assay
etc so there's many parameters that will
be included in all assays but there are
also some assays specific parameters
that you'd want to look at depending on
the methodology so in here in the for
the case of Pro and capelin this is an
immunoassay and immunoassay obviously
has antibodies that will bind to the
target peptide or target protein of
interest so things that might you might
want to look at for evaluation here are
interferences by heterophile antibodies
potentially if the antibody interaction
uses a biotin streptavidin mediated
interaction then potentially biotin
exogenous biotin might interfere and
that you may have heard about this
recently in in the new FDA warning that
came out for patients who are taking
either over-the-counter or prescription
biotin supplements that does interfere
with some immunoassays out there and
then so that's for the case of
immunoassay so you really have to know
what assay it is that you're doing the
chemistry behind it to understand some
of the analytic evaluations that you you
will need to perform in the case that
dr. muse had talked about before this it
was a mass spectrometry based assay so
very different analytical evaluations
might need to be done based on that that
methodology so I so there are compounds
extraction efficiencies etc so again the
analytic evaluation will be different
will have different parameters based on
the assay platform in this case for pro
and kathlynn we're talking about
immunoassay platform does not use biotin
so we don't need to worry about that and
so some examples of some of the analytic
validation that was performed I won't go
into details about those because dr.
mucin did a nice job in his presentation
but you know we we did perform of course
within and between running assay
precision studies again using different
concentrations of patient pooled plasma
at different concentrations within the
analytical measuring range we evaluated
the accuracy this can be done by either
comparing to a reference method or you
know spiking in known concentrations of
purified compound into SA matrix and
making sure that you can recover that
known concentration so there's several
different ways of performing accuracy
studies analytical measuring range
mixing you know high and low samples
together and making sure that the
recovery is is linear within that a mr
your limit of quantitation so you want
to make sure that different well you
want to define the lowest reportable
value in your concentration range that
has that you can measure precisely and
then of course we evaluated our
reference intervals we defined a hundred
and twenty
normal donors in a collective plasma
from them and calculated a central 95th
percentile in that healthy normal donor
concept of cohort evaluated analytical
specificity in this case looking for
potential interference from hemolysis or
hypertriglyceridemia or even elevated
bilirubin things like that
some example data that we can show all
of this data is actually in under
submission at a from in a manuscript but
some data that I will show you here is
precision at low mid and high
concentrations within the prone kefflin
analytical measuring rein and range in
all CDs were less than 5% linearity
studies are shown in the bottom with
linearity ranges shown to be from high
to low concentrations as shown here
and then reference interval data shown
from our healthy reference population
again patients with that are deemed by
us to be healthy and wouldn't have
abnormal Pro and kesselmann
concentrations with no renal dysfunction
and and so you can see that there's no
in this cohort no age or gender
difference
and lastly we after performing the
analytical validation then we went to it
after being being satisfied with the
with the performance of the analytic
validation then we went on to evaluate
this marker clinically so in our patient
cohort what we did was we identified
over 1,100 patients with varying renal
functions and comorbidities and you can
see the breakdown of the individuals
here they range from patients who were
being evaluated as a potential kidney
donor so these would be individuals who
would obviously have sufficient renal
function if they're if they're being
evaluated as a potential kidney donor
all the way down to folks who have very
severe chronic kidney disease and those
folks would obviously have a compromised
renal function and all patients in this
cohort had measured GFR by is Alamut
clearance and what then we did was we
measured Pro and kefflin in all of these
patients who were seen for various
reasons but had measured GFR
concentrations and we measure piant Pro
and capelin and compared to their
measured GFR and so what we saw in our
study is identical very similar to what
has been published is that Pro and
capsule and negatively associated with
GFR and our patient population and that
we could potentially use Pro and kefflin
in a model to estimate GFR in these
patients and ongoing studies will will
are ongoing and will be needed to
determine if an equation can be used
using P NK for estimation of GFR
so that's the first biomarker that I
wanted to talk about and then the second
one I'll go over a little bit more
quickly as neuro Tencent neuro Tencent
is a thirteen amino acid peptide hormone
it's produced in the small intestine
after intake of saturated fat and it
stimulates pancreatic secretion and
colonic motility and it actually
suppresses feelings of hunger the
problem and this may sound familiar from
the previous biomarker is that neuro
tension the peptide is very unstable
with a half-life of around two minutes
obviously not very conducive to
measuring in the laboratory since it
will be essentially gone by the time it
gets to the laboratory for measurement
so very similar to the to the story that
I told you before for pro and capelin
for pro for neuro tension the assay has
been dub NSA has been developed for
measuring again a stable peptide from
Pro neuro tension the parent protein
that makes the active peptide Narottam
s'en but again an immunoassay has been
developed for a stable peptide called
from the pro neuro tension that is much
more amenable for for measurement in the
laboratory and is made obviously
produced an equal molar concentration to
the active neuro Tencent peptide
it turns out that prone er attention and
the neuro tension one receptor are
expressed highly in breast cancer
tissues and you can see Western blots
shown on this slide
and in two studies the Malmo diet and
cancer study as well as the memo
prevention project it turns out that
patients with height the highest
concentrations of pro neuro Tencent and
circulation and in plasma are at the
highest risk of incident breast cancer
and it's important that that you realize
this is incident breast cancer and not
recurrence which really is is great to
have a new biomarker in this area for
potentially identifying patients for
incidence of breast cancer so for this
reason we in the laboratory as well as
our clinical colleagues found this to be
a promising biomarker and we're not as
far along with evaluating this one but
we're well on our way so we've actually
already completed our analytical
validation very similar steps that that
I outlined for the for the studies that
we perform with pro and kefflin so I
won't go through them again here but
because the assay platform is very
similar it's another Eliza based assay
very similar analytic valid evaluation
that we did and all parameters performed
really very nicely throughout the
clinically relevant measuring range and
so on the next steps that we have
ongoing are that we're evaluating a
clinical evaluation study on partnering
the laboratory with our clinical
colleagues and collecting patient
samples to be able to evaluate this
biomarker and our own patient population
here at Mayo Clinic
through the collaboration with mango
tech we've actually formed a formal
collaborative research partnership such
that we at Mayo Clinic will be
performing these research studies with
Mayo Clinic patient samples but then
we've also opened this project up to be
a testing site for outside researchers
who have interests in the biomarkers
that are produced by Sango Tech the two
biomarkers that I presented here both
Pro and Catalan and Pro neuro Tenten as
well as other biomarkers under
development at Bingo tech such that we
would be a testing site for researchers
outside of Mayo Clinic who actually
might want to do some research on these
by using these biomarkers in their own
patient samples but don't have the means
to bring up the assay themselves and
this is a unique partnership between
Stingo tech and Mayo Clinic that offers
us a unique research perspective here at
Mayo Clinic to further patient care for
the research and hopefully improve the
health of our patients and those
everywhere around the world
so in conclusion today I hope what we
have done is given you a sense of what
it might take to transition a biomart
from the basic research setting again a
setting where either basic researchers
or companies in either the academic
field or in the you know more private
private area have actually done the
research to develop these assays
identifying the biomarkers of interest
and develop the even develop assays but
haven't transitioned it to clinical use
so I'm hoping you a sense of the efforts
that it takes in the clinical laboratory
to take that research and do the end of
both the analytical and the clinical
evaluations in a hospital setting to
then be be confident in the assay
performance both analytically that
you're getting the right number and
clinically that the the number that you
get will be useful for patient care it
certainly is a lot of work is time
consuming but hopefully with a lot of
gains for the for patient care at the
end
so with that we would certainly like to
end and take any any questions
absolutely thank you dr. Jaffe dr.
Newsome and dr. Donato for your
presentations a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
the speakers will answer as many
questions as time permits so let's see
our first question of the day doctors
asks how do you learn about new
biomarkers and partner with basic
researchers or companies that have
discovered them
you
so thank you for the question we we're
at a large academic Medical Center and
so having we had to certainly have the
resources worth both personnel and and
equipment to have the means to evaluate
these biomarkers and then specifically
about how to make the connections I
think it's really important to network
at national national and international
meetings where both representatives from
academia as well as as pharmaceutical
and biotechnology companies are there to
start conversations about what's what's
new what's out there what's on the
horizon and how can we be a part of
evaluating the next generation of
biomarkers to advance patient care
excellent thank you so much for your
response our second question asks how do
you know what specific validation
studies need to be performed
fairly straightforward and that there is
a whole list of accreditation agencies
that have already made the rules for us
obviously we want to make sure that we
do an excellent job and we follow due
diligence so that we're providing
results that can be trustworthy and
useful in patient care but as far as
what specific experiments are required
the College of American Pathologists as
well as the New York State Department of
Health and CMS all have lists that are
readily available and we also involve a
plan and involve a plan right from the
beginning that includes not only an
analytic validation but the ability to
know that in some way whether it is
because of a sample Bank that is
available or because we plan to do a
prospective study that we will be able
to do at least a modest clinical
evaluation to make sure that the results
in Mayo Clinic patients and in the areas
that we serve will have similar results
to what we've seen in the literature
okay thank you for your response our
third question asks how does your lab
determine which tests to work on their
variety of considerations one includes
what sorts of gaps we see in and what
needs we see if we're going to go
testing we are always attracted to those
areas which will for most patients as is
the mantra of the Mayo Clinic but the
second important consideration is the
ability to implement that sort of
testing both analytically and clinically
we have fairly extensive and
sophisticated resources but we can't do
everything and we therefore have to pick
and choose those areas where we have
tremendous expertise so it makes no
sense for us to emerge to use a
technology that we're not familiar with
instead we focus on those areas where we
can make the technology fit and finally
given we want to do both annele
and a clinical validation we have to
have the ideas that in the long run we
will be able to look and validate that
what we're doing is clinically useful
because a simple analytic validation
even though it takes a lot of work is
not adequate for us to advocate to the
world that this is something that may be
helpful to patients
all right thank you our next question
let's see this one asks how long does
the development and validation process
take
yeah this this well it's highly variable
from test to test but it is quite
lengthy and in all honesty the
validation the analytical validation
that we've we've outlined in the several
tests that we've talked about today
again they're fairly straightforward
assays or experiments and we run through
them as fast as we can so actually
that's probably the fastest part to to
get through the analytical validation
part were actually quite quite have
quite a smooth-running machine there for
that and our laboratory technologists
are very very equipped at doing that I
would say the longest part can be the
clinical validation part and this has a
lot to do with what dr. Jaffe was
talking about earlier in the previous
question because you really do have to
identify patients who you can collect
samples either residual samples or
prospectively collect them to validate
the si is in some sort of clinical
cohort and so this can take quite a bit
of time especially if it's a prospective
collection with IRB approval needed and
important informed consent if it's a if
it's a previous cohort that we have a
previous study Bank already collected a
frozen cohort that that is much easier
and can speed up the timeline quite a
bit because essentially all you would
need to do is is an IRB modification to
add that particular study if the
patients have already given informed
consent for future studies using that
sample and then you're off to the races
and can just test in the assay so so
really it is variable it's hard to give
a timeline certainly six months would be
very I would be ideal it can be even
longer and then of course even outside
the laboratory then we get into the test
build process which as probably most
clinicians laboratory laboratory ins out
there
that that IT resources are challenging
to them just just the activities of
building the test so that it can take
quite a while if I can put on my
administrative hat and remind my
colleagues that we have a very robust
infrastructure that we fund based on the
education research and development funds
of the institution that give us
additional personnel so that we're not
competing with the production aspect of
the laboratory
excellent excellent thank you so much uh
let's see we got a couple more questions
coming in uh the next question asks what
is the difference between tests which
are available for research youths and
moves that are clinically available
gallon analytically speaking if this
test is something that we are offering
for research use and commercially you
know telling people it's available I
will say analytically there is no
difference
that means if it's gotten to that stage
we've vetted the precision the accuracy
we believe the number that we report is
the truth however the reason we would
perhaps hesitate and making this
available clinically is there's either
not enough data or even conflicting data
in the literature etc about the utility
or what this might mean for patient care
interactions so that would be the only
reason we would hold off on making
something ready clinically
all right thank you and appears we only
have time for one more question today
how does your lab determine when a test
is ready for clinical use
well again it has to be analytically
robust and meet the highest standards
and the laboratory procedures mandate it
has to be capable of going through the
approval process whether it is FDA New
York State CLIA cap or anything else and
it has to have at least a modern modicum
of a robust clinical validation that
says it will help patients
I would like to once again thank dr.
Jaffe
dr. mutant and dr. Donato for their
presentations doctors do you have any
final comments
we've enjoyed having all of you with us
thank you well thanks thank you I'd like
to thank the audience for joining us
today and for their interesting
questions we would also like to thank
our speakers from the Mayo Clinic and
our sponsor spin otac for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on-demand through July of
2018 lab routes will alert you via email
when it is available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live events until next time
goodbye
from lab routes